the stock market's panicking but you
don't have to
yeah i mean it it's really uh if you
have money now it'll be a great time to
make money you can buy stocks
at you know it you know when they hit a
floor or when you think they're at a
floor you can buy bitcoin this is when
people get rich right rich people get
even richer when they have the
opportunity to go in and swoop in and
buy things
um
that other so i mean i don't know if you
are in a financial position to monitor
this stuff and go in and buy some stuff
it could be nice
and you could look back on it years from
now why don't you but why don't we buy
baby formula and sell it like like buy
it up in bulk
could we do that is there any law
preventing us probably but from buying
baby formula in bulk and then going to
poor areas and selling it
yeah because grocery stores can buy them
in bulk right so so could we i mean it's
a great idea to just buy instead of
merch
on our website let's just sell baby
formula at an increased cost it's called
arbitrage
it happens all the time
buy baby formula and sell it to be and
let's be uh it's not the time this is
great now they're overturning roe v wade
nobody has formula
those babies do not need to be here
truly
and the reality is those babies are
gonna show up hungry
for formula which we don't have so it's
time for the supreme court to [ __ ]
relax
and [ __ ] extend abortion to seven or
eight months even
really on the operating day at this
point the economy demands on the
operating table
depending on the price of formula that
day you should be able to
get rid of it
if formula is high
the week before you're about to give
birth
they should have a special
before they overturn roe v wade what if
they did this they're gonna overturn it
but they said for the next six months
because of the shortages on formula and
how expensive everything is we are
planning to overturn roe v wade but for
the next six months abortion is legal up
into an including day of birth
just to
you know
just get in while the getting's good
and then we're banning it
but up to including the day of birth
where they will you literally give birth
to a baby
and they give it lethal injection
[Laughter]
on the opera
what on the operating table
because
right now we financially can't do it
it's like have you ever wanted a puppy
and your parents had to go we can't do
it right now
people are desperate
we we can't even control the babies we
have here in our country we certainly
can't be bringing we should do a chinese
style ban on birth
uh not i'm not even kid for 100 percent
get a bitcoin if you want to have a kid
and see if you can watch that for a year
with the highs and lows of that it's
[ __ ] pretty much like a lot of people
say oh having kids greatest thing in
your life have you owned a bitcoin
the highs and the lows oh your kids your
kid just won a a [ __ ] hockey game
everyone's happy with bitcoins hi oh the
kid broke his arm in the next hockey
game i'm worried bitcoin's low
a bitcoin is a perfect uh replacement
for a child all the highs and lows that
you used to get from a traditional
nuclear family structure you can now get
from cryptocurrency yes or yes yes
you don't need a bunch of children
running around your house
unless you're the ant you want to do
blood rituals with them you don't need
them
running around your house
you can get all of that fulfillment and
drama from bitcoin
if you own crypto and you watch it go up
and down
what do people do when they have a kid
they have all this mommy [ __ ] right
mommy bloggers they watch youtubes of
mommy we've got that the crypto
community has all of that you can watch
will clementi that uh [ __ ] uh 19 year
old autistic twink and he just sits
there and he rattles off things all day
listen all you can clearly
[Music]
replace your need to have children
with
the bitcoin
world just buy a bitcoin a bitcoin costs
30 000
okay
that's essentially the startup cost of
having a baby when you think of the
cribs and the stuff and it only gets
more expensive from there my point is
that
it's incredibly irresponsible right now
to have children we need to put like a
year or two moratorium on all birth in
america
where if you if
you're laughing but i'm not wrong the
reason china's overtaking us
is because they don't get emotional
about this [ __ ]
moratorium on all birth
for one to two years of every race don't
even come at me with that it's not about
that
every race
close the doctors and hospitals down in
the ob gyns close it down treat mothers
like criminals put them in jail
and forcibly abort their children for a
period of one to two years until the
economy can rebound and give them crypto
while you're give them crypto
so they can [ __ ] have something to
watch and care about every day and look
after give them cryptocurrency take
their babies from them
and kill them
we don't have the money it's incredibly
selfish to keep bringing life into this
world when we have artificial
intelligence ai we have enough simulated
life we don't need any more biological
life we've got enough
elon things are getting better elon musk
is buying twitter he's gonna let me
threaten to kill my aunt on twitter
again
things are gonna be okay
elon's gonna let me uh put my answer
dress on twitter and tell people to go
kill her
i think isn't that what this is about
isn't elon buying twitter
specifically so that i can encourage my
fans to go kill my aunt
if that's not what it's about i'm not
even excited about it anymore that's my
question
my question is simply
i i'm sick of this baby [ __ ] all the
time i'm sick of arguing about it
i'm saying
i'm let's let's not only should we not
ban roe v wade
we should ban birth
go the other way and just until
inflation comes down
until the cost surprise how bad is the
the cost right now of the food